union des ministres des affaires
étrangères de la coalition anti dèche
aujourd'hui à rome une rencontre sous
l'impulsion du chef de la diplomatie
américaine
anthony blinken actuellement en tournée
en europe et italienne luigi di maio les
83 ministres membres de cette coalition
discuteront des moyens de lutte contre
des ch et son influence justement on en
parle tout de suite avec pierre martinet
les directeurs de wind corp security
défense et ex haut cadre du service
action de la dgse champ bonjour merci
d'être avec nous en direct car martinez
alors d'abord cette coalition mondiale
contre des gens qui regroupe 3 83
membres
quel est son bilan vient écouter cette
coalition a quand même
le bilan est mondiale et est
relativement positif parce que l'état
l'état islamique en tant que tel en tant
que territoire a éclaté un sous l'action
des de la coalition militaire au sol et
dans les airs en revanche la l'état
islamique faut pas crier victoire sur
toute la ligne car l'état islamique
l'idéologie quelle qu'elles propagent
est toujours présent et l'état islamique
s'est restructuré de façon plus
clandestine
il continue à opérer sur des territoires
en afrique au moyen-orient au pakistan
l'afghanistan par des attentats mais
au-delà de ça il y a toujours cette
idéologie qui prospère qui a lieu qui
n'a de cesse de prospérer depuis des
années alors non il ne faut pas crier
victoire
l'état islamique quatre romans se
restructurer de façon comment dirais-je
la plus physique et surtout il n'y a pas
que l'état islamique je rappelle qu'il
ya à peu près une vingtaine de groupes
islamistes armés dans le monde qui est
capable de 2d commettre des attentats et
d'imposer la charia quand la violence et
aussi par dans l'idéologie
alors c'est vrai qu'on sait vous
coût 10 que des shows finalement été
vaincue dans certaines parties du monde
mais c'est vrai que c'est une question
aujourd'hui qui revient sur la table
parce que la ministre des affaires
étrangères belge elle avait déclaré en
mars lors d'une précédente réunion que
l'état islamique comme vous le disiez
s'adapte et constitue toujours une
nouvelle menace
ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça veut
dire que c'est une guerre asymétrique
ça veut dire que selon moi le triptyque
de l'islamisme c'est l'idéologie qui est
beaucoup plus importante que que tout le
reste il y a le financement qui est une
deuxième partie est la troisième partie
c'est l'action violente
l'action violente se matérialisent se
matérialisent depuis de nombreuses
années mais en particulier de pions
septembre 2000 2001 par des attentats
par des attentats qui sont là pour
marquer les et pignons pour créer de la
psychose mais qui selon moi ne sont pas
le plus efficace le plus efficace c'est
l'idéologie du quotidien qui n'a de
cesse de prospérer en permanence et je
prends un exemple très factuelle est
très récent
c'est pendant l'euro de football on le
refus des musulmans de devoir d'écouter
date de peut-être sans alcool local 0 l
alcool sur à côté de toute cette
propagande religieuse n'a de cesse de
prospérer depuis 2001
vous avez utilisé un mot important
propagande ça aussi c'est un pan qui
compte aussi pour un des ch pour
justement entretenir ses réseaux et son
influence mais absolument
alors il y a aujourd'hui en occident et
en europe en particulier parce que tout
le monde considère que l'europe c'est
vraiment le laboratoire de l'islamisme
de l'islamisme de façon idéologique des
façons et également pour les attentats
il y a au quotidien de la propagande
pour de la revendication religieuse pour
faire avancer ses idées là et elles sont
l avance plus facilement mais que nous
dirigent plus facilement et dans le
temps de façon idéologique
les attentats sont là pour créer la
psychose sont là aussi
pour certes pour certains de créer des
heurts intercommunautaires pour
déstabiliser certaines régions certains
pays
certaines villes et pourquoi pas qu'il y
ait des attentats contre mu contre les
musulmans pour soulever certaines
populations musulmanes contre l'occident
en revanche la propagande you du
quotidien si on ne fait rien pour
stopper l'influencent des frères
musulmans
l' influence du salafisme l'influencent
delà de la turquie avec milo bruce en
europe
l'état islamique a de beaux jours devant
lui la même titre que que boko haram que
que les shebab en somalie que que al
qaida en afrique et ailleurs c'est celle
à qui il y à vraiment le combat à mener
et ses pas et c'est pas une coalition de
83 pays ça serait une colle une
coalition de tout l'occident contre 7
contre ce phénomène qui a commencé en
1928 à vous parlais tout à l'heure des
réseaux de dèche en afrique que sait-on
sur ses réseaux et comment est-ce qu'ils
aient voulu vous avez cité boko haram
les al shebab al qaïda ce sont des
groupes jihadistes qui sont même ceux
cités comme concurrent de dèche ce que
c'est le cas alors moi je pense pas
qu'il y ait de concurrence ils ont tous
le même projet ils veulent ils veulent
de façon différente imposer la charia
est retrouvée parce qu'ils avaient avant
l'état islamique a pris les devants a
pris les devants par rapport al qaïda
qui était plus dans la clandestinité
avec des réseaux avec des filières avant
2001 qui a exposé au grand jour avec
avec j'attends les attentats du 11
septembre
ils ont les thaïs avis que juste pour
rappel que l'état islamique vient d'al
qaïda c'était al qaïda en irak qui s'est
ensuite qui s'est ensuite restructurer
en état islamique
dès que al bagdadi a créé son état on va
dire structures et les réseaux sont
multiple il y a aujourd'hui de nombreux
groupes de nongo petit groupe qui se
revendique d'al-qaïda qui se
revendiquent de l'état islamique et
[Musique]
signe qu'ils n'ont de cesse que de
d'imposer la charia alors il y adhérer
des réseaux il ya des succursales
j'ose dire si j'ose dire qu'il met ainsi
qu'ils vont imposer leur idéologie de
façon locale régionale nationale et
internationale ce qu'ils sont capables
d'imposer cette idéologie de façon
internationale sont les plus les plus
représentatives si al qaïda c'est celle
état islamique aujourd'hui élèves le
reste c'est de façon régionales ils sont
en train de ils sont en train d'imposer
leur idéologie sur leur territoire pour
l'instant ça leur suffit
et ensuite il y à des rafles des
ramifications l'image de la pieuvre
islamique islamistes pour moi est très
très significative très significative
est représentatif de ce qui se passe
depuis 1928 en occident et en
particulier en europe il suffit de voir
en vente à quel point l'idéologie de c2c
groupe et c'est important
merci beaucoup à vous pierre martinet
directeur de whincup sécurité défense ex
cadre du service action de la dgse